Thanks Veto.
And now it's time
to install the Sunshine app
on our phones.
So to get started,
let's grab a USB cable.
We'll plug in our device and then
we'll need to enable USB debugging.
This can be found in Developer options
in the Settings app.
But note that on Android
devices 4.2 and above,
the option is actually hidden by default.
To find the secret menu,
go to the Settings app.
Scroll down to About Phone.
Then go down to Build Number
and tap on that seven times.
Then, when you go back to Settings,
you'll see the Developer
options menu appear.
Also, set up your computer
to detect your device.
Check the instructor notes
for more details.
We're going to continue
using a device because it's faster
and smoother for development.
But if you don't have one, that's okay.
You can continue using the emulator
that we created previously.